♪♪
-Let's get to the news!
During his remarks at
Saturday's White House
Correspondents' Dinner,
President Biden said,
"American democracy
is not a reality show."
And he's right.
Reality shows get
much better ratings.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
President Biden's
approval rating
has increased slightly
over the last two months,
and now the White House
is scrambling like hell
to figure out what he did.
"Did he change his hair?
A different mask?
What tie was he wearing?"
That's right, President Biden's
approval rating
has increased to 42%.
He now ranks slightly above
leaf blowers.
[ Laughter ]
At his rally in Nebraska
yesterday,
former president Trump appeared
to misremember Ohio Republican
Senate candidate
J.D. Vance's name
and called him J.D. Mandel.
That's bad enough, but then he
said, "J.D. Mandel will win
or my name isn't Donald Vance."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll, just
35% of college students said
they like Elon Musk more than
other megabillionaires.
Said Musk, "Oh, yeah?
How much to buy college?"
[ Laughter ]
"Not just yours.
The whole idea."
[ Laughter ]
After the share price of Meta
increased by over 17% last week,
CEO Mark Zuckerberg became $11
billion wealthier in one day.
Then that became $12 billion
when he stuck his hand
in the pocket of a hoodie
he hadn't worn in a while.
[ Laughter ]
"Ooh, that's fortuitous."
A couple recently got married on
a Southwest flight to Las Vegas
and then immediately started
watching different movies.
[ Laughter ]
It deserved better.
That's a wonderful joke.
I didn't think it would go well.
[ Laughter ]
But it was too good not to do.
A lot of you aren't married yet,
but you're going to be,
and then one day you're going to
be lying in bed
and you're going to realize how
[bleep] funny that joke was.
[ Laughter ]
I'm willing -- You know what?
I'm willing to make
that investment now.
[ Laughter ]
Equity. That joke has equity.
That's right.
A couple recently got married on
a Southwest flight to Las Vegas,
and like most couples
who go to Vegas,
decided to get divorced
on the flight back.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
more than half of Americans want
their family to have access
to their personal phone
and computer data
after they die.
The other half are men.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a single lottery
ticket was sold in Arizona
last week that won the
$473 million Powerball jackpot,
and the big winner was --
Aw, damn it!
[ Laughter ]
After Politico
reported on a draft
of a Supreme Court
majority opinion
that overturned Roe vs. Wade,
Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
tweeted yesterday that it was
"The most significant and
glorious news of our lifetime."
Now, I'm not a legal scholar,
but I do know this --
if you made that lady happy,
you did something very bad.
President Biden
released a statement today
about the leaked
Supreme Court opinion
and said that if abortion rights
are rolled back,
voters will have to elect
more pro-choice officials
in the midterms.
Okay, you got to stop
putting this on the voters.
You're the president with
control of the House and Senate.
We did the voting thing.
That's like me blaming
a bad show on an intern.
Does it feel good in the moment?
Yeah!
It feels great,
but, at the end of the day,
we all know whose fault it
really is -- Wally's.
Health officials
announced yesterday
that the coronavirus infections
in New York City
have reached
a medium-risk threat level,
which means you have to go from
not wearing a mask
to wearing it below your nose.
According to
unconfirmed reports,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
is set to
undergo cancer surgery.
Doctors think that
with their sharpest skills
and a little luck,
they can remove all the Putin.
According to a new study,
a dog's personality has
nothing to do with its breed.
For example, a different collie
pushed Timmy into the well.
The series "Grey's Anatomy"
yesterday celebrated
filming its 400th episode.
That show has been on so long,
all the doctors
are patients now.
A house in Dayton, Ohio, that
has been decorated to look like
Monica's apartment from
the sitcom "Friends"
is currently up for sale
for $162,000,
which is also what
the monthly rent would be
for Monica's apartment
in Manhattan.
And, finally,
the luxury gym Equinox
will reportedly begin
accepting cryptocurrency
as a form of
payment this summer,
while Planet Fitness will begin
accepting Marlboro Miles.
Vice President Kamala Harris
spoke yesterday
at a gala for a pro-abortion
rights organization and said,
"Those Republican leaders
who are trying to weaponize the
use of the law against women,
well, we say, how dare they."
Great.
That oughta do it.
[ Laughter ]
And, if that doesn't stop them,
you can always throw in
a "Harumph?!"
[ Laughter ]
Microsoft co-founder Bill Gates
spoke out yesterday
against the potential reversal
of the Supreme Court's decision
in Roe v Wade
and warned that it would
"set us back 50 years."
He said the next time America
makes that much progress,
we should remember to hit save.
[ Laughter and applause ]
In a new interview,
Maryland Governor Larry Hogan
said that former President Trump
should not run for reelection
and added that Trump is
"enjoying playing golf
five or six day as week."
Why ruin that
by going back to a job
where he could only play
four or five days a week?
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
President Biden is set to hold
a Cinco de Mayo party tomorrow
at the White House,
because what's more fun
than a Cinco de Mayo
party thrown
by someone who doesn't drink?
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's like having
a Halloween party
and saying, "But FYI,
this is a no-sugar house.
Who loves raisins?!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
NASA is planning on sending
naked images of humans
into space
as part of a new mission
to communicate
with alien civilizations.
Guys, you can't do that.
At the very least,
you have to hit them
with a "U up?" first.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally,
the NFL announced today
that the New York Giants
will play a game
against the Green Bay Packers
this season in London.
So, instead of losing
27 to nothing,
the Giants will lose 27-nil.
[ Laughter ]
"The New York Times" has
published additional audio
of House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
and the aftermath
of the Capitol attack.
All right, how do we have this
much audio of Kevin McCarthy?
Pretty soon, we're gonna be able
to put out an E.P..
[ Laughter ]
President Biden said yesterday
that his administration
is making progress on reducing
the national debt.
Oh, good, that was
definitely the thing I was
most worried about.
[ Laughter ]
What about abortion,
the pandemic, climate change?
The Democrats are like the
people who offer
to bring the most boring
thing to a party.
"Good news, everyone, the
napkins are here!"
[ Laughter ]
"The soiree can begin!"
President Biden warned yesterday
that the leaked opinion
that indicated the Supreme Court
is prepared to overturn
Roe v. Wade could threaten
other freedoms and said,
"What happens if you have states
change the laws
saying that children who are
LGBTQ can't be in classrooms
with other children?"
Said Republicans,
"Oh, hey, that's good.
That's good."
[ Laughter ]
"What else you got?"
Florida Congressman Matt Gaetz
tweeted yesterday...
Which is pretty bold coming
from a guy
who does all his dating
on Venmo.
[ Laughter ]
Several journalists across
multiple news outlets
have reportedly tested positive
for the coronavirus
after attending last weekend's
White House
Correspondents' Dinner.
So all those articles about how
we're back to normal
are gonna be a week late.
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump Jr. reportedly
met on Tuesday
with the House Committee
investigating
the Capitol attack remotely
for more than three hours.
Three hours doesn't seem
very long,
but because it's Don Jr.,
it still came out
to like eight hours' worth
of testimony.
-The media runs right away.
It's Russian disinformation.
There's literally zero evidence
that it's Russian dis--
[ Laughter ]
-President Biden mistakenly said
at a White House event this week
that there's never been
a senator from Delaware.
While the GOP is trying
to convince us there's
never been a congressman
from North Carolina.
[ Laughter ]
Sunday is Mother's Day,
which means today is
"I got plenty of time
to get a card."
Tomorrow is
"I should get a card."
Saturday is
"What about an e-card?"
And Sunday is "I'm screwed."
[ Laughter ]
Residents of Nantucket voted
yesterday to allow
everyone to go topless
on its beaches,
bringing them one step closer
to finally living up
to their limericks.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
An otter -- Yeah, sometimes
it takes a minute
for the limerick jokes to land.
[ Laughter ]
We'll be patient.
An otter was recently spotted
swimming in the Detroit River
for the first time
in over 100 years.
But I'm willing to bet
that it's a different otter.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the FDA is looking
at a new proposed rule
to ban menthol cigarettes.
Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment called
"Is This Racist?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The FDA is going to ban
menthol cigarettes,
and that's ra-- well...
I mean, it is...
[ Laughter ]
Okay. No, wait.
[ Stammers ]
I mean, it feels ra--
[ Laughter ]
But is it, like,
all-the-way racist?
I -- Okay, okay, okay.
You gotta look at the -- uh...
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ] Yeah,
'cause if I say that,
then that means
the other thing, so,
dicey, dicey, dicey.
Uh...Okay. Wait.
I got it.
It is racist, because
the other cigarettes
are, well -- that's different.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Wait.
Okay.
Yeah, okay, wait, no.
Not racist, final answer.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!
-Wait! No, I mean --
♪♪